Allah Allah altüst olmak ve Can havliyle
karar vermek bana hep çok şey kazandırdı
zorluklarda bana çok şey kazandırdı çok
dramatik bir çocukluğu yok Çok acayip
yerlerden gelip ismini onların en
tepesinde yazsın diye falan öyle bir
hayal mayal de etmedim 20 sene evli
kalmış ve anlaşamayan bir arabanın
çocuğuyum Ben anneme dedim ki Anne neden
20 sene evli kaldım ya o kadar Başka bir
adam ağzı laf yapan becerikli Yemeyi
içmeyi gezmeyi seven bir babam var benim
Öyle çok yakışıklı böyle ama çok gezen
Tozan da bir adam Annem de böyle
kaynıyor bir cacık Ayşe Kadın fasulye
öyle mutlu klasik bir
ben hiç çalışmamış Neden neden 20 sene
evli kaldım kadın 20 senesi tabi
çocukların için evli kaldım Gidecek
yerim yoktu dedi bir anneannelere
giderdik Biz yayınlara giderdik bir
teyzemlere gider giderdik hakikaten
İlkokul 5 sene beş ayrı ilkokulda
okuduğum Ben İlkokulu bir yerlere
giderdik biz annemle babam küsünce
barıştırır lardı sonra yine eve gelirdi
ki öyle bir şiddete ya da kötü bir şeye
şahit olmadım ama mutsuz bir evliliğin
kokusu Cindy üzerime bir de şu Cindy
üzerime gidecek bir yerim yoktu Bir evim
yoktu gidiyordum dönüyordum güçlü kadın
olmayı belki Buradan ezberledi hayat
bana Babam da hep erken kalk hızlı
gönderdi yani erkek hızlı hızlı yürü
erken kalk hızlı yürü
sabah erken kalktım ve hızlı Yurdum hep
önden gitmeye çalıştım Ama benden
başarılı olan insanların canını yapmadan
yapmaya çalıştım bunu ve benden başarılı
olan insanlar hep dikkatle özel ve
saygıyla dinledim yahoo7 ne bilmiyoruz
biz yapmışsa yapmış birinin canını
yapmak istiyorsak ki yapmayalım niye Can
yapıyoruz daha başarılı olarak yapalım
onun yaptıklarını daha da güzelini
yapmaya çalışarak yapalım onu oradan
aşağı indirmek beni daha başarılı
kırmayacak ki arkadaşlar Bana diyorlar
ki ya Sen ekrana çıktığında niye kendin
gibi olmuyorsun benle konuşur gibi ol
Rahat ol Tabii sen memleketin Dayağını
yemiyorsun ki sen ringe çıkmıyorsun ki
senin canına okuyorlar ki Sağlı sollu
haftada üç gün altüst oluyorum Ben 26
senedir bu işi yapıyorum Beni altüst
etmekten yorulmadı lar Ben Nasır tuttum
ve alt üst oldu
eve gidiyorum artık gerçekten bu bir
yaşam şekli haline dönüştüğü zaman eğer
ben saldırılara savunma ile cevap
verseydim hiçbir şey olmasaydı gelirdim
benim sahneye çıktığımda yaptığım iş sür
evleri benzerleri rakipleri olabilir ama
bu meslek öyle bir meslek ki ringe
çıktığınızda dayak yemeye hazır
olmalısınız Bunun sebebini anlamam
gerçekten çok uzun yıllar sürdü Bir
insan bir şeyi yapıyorsa biraz da farklı
olmak için çaba sarf ediyorsa ve kendini
geliştirmek için yollar arıyordu ve bir
Antalya açık fikrimdir bayılırım
öğrenmeye bir sıfatlı bir şey mi yapıyor
oraya gider onu sorarım başka şeyler
araştırırım biyografiler okurum ne
yapmışlar daha farklı ve iyi hissetmiş
kendine bunu herkes yapıyor Ben nasıl
yapabilirim diye kendi çapımda kendimce
araştırmayı sevdiğim için hep ölümü
tıkamak istediler bunun yolunu
Ben 15 sene önce araştırma yaparak
buldum bir kaliteli araştırmada Focus
Grup araştırmasında aynalı odanın
arkasında buldum kendime ve bir grup
insan Gülben Ergen'le ilgili konuşuyor
seven var sevmeyen var ev kadını var
öğrenci var çalışanlar var ayrı ayrı
gruplar aynalı camın arkasında
dinliyorum bir taktik ben onu dizilerden
severim Çok tatlı bir kızdır ömürde ki
ya bunlar mankenlikten gelmeyin lütfen
niye çıksa iki tane şarkı söylüyorlar
buluyorlar parayı üründeki Yok yok Ama
kendine gelmedi Ben sözlükten geldi
diyor Öbür de ki bunları para için
yapamayacağı hiçbir şey yok Ah Herkes
başka başka şeyler düşünüyor kendim gibi
olmakla nasıl algılandığı mım arasında
geçen yol Vakit kaybı sahip olduğumuz
şöhreti beğeni tanınma ün sevgin
ederseniz değilim faydalı işlere
kullanmak için kendime bir yol
bu ama bunu çok erken yaşlarda düştüm
bir dernek başkanı olmadan önce o
Derneği kurmadan önce uzun yıllar Türkan
Saylan da çalıştığım mesela Baba Beni
Okula Gönder kampanyası Haydi Kızlar
Okula kampanyası Bunlar da uzun yıllar
çalıştım ama oralarda çalışırken
öğrendiğim çok şey vardı hayatın
gerçekleriyle sahneye çıktığı zaman ki
gerçekler aynı değil sokağa çıktık
insanların içine gir mesela yıllar sonra
bana Hürriyet gazetesinin kelebek ekinde
röportajlar yapmam teklif edildiğinde
topu futbol topu merkezlerinde dönem
kürtaj yapabilirdim ve İstanbul'da işini
bitirdim çok daha kolay olurdu Haftada
bir gün yazılarımı teslim ediyordum
güncelliği giden var mı İçinizde
ne demiş bezeye gittim ben
mı orada
bir kahraman bir çocuk tanıdım çok
enteresandır gerçekten Çoban Mahir Mahir
müthiş bir çocuk Robert Koleji burslu
kazanıyor çemişgezek'te çobanlık
yaparken ben Mersin'e gittim ilmek
uçakla tanıştım bitiş bir kadınım bütün
Mersin'deki köyünde yaşayan kadınları
kaldırmış hepsine tiyatro eğitimi
veriyor tiyatrolar kuruyor Mersin'de
tiyatro yönetmenliği yapıyor Ronaldo'nun
yönetmenliğini yapıyor acayip bir kadın
Erzurum'da Ömer öğretmeni tanıdım köy
köy dolaşıp bütün köy okullarına ve
çocuklara yardım ediyor Bunlar benim
yaşamımın hep kahramanları oldular hep
hırsız edilen bana ne fıstık adı
Yok yok Bana sorarsanız ben kendimi
Azimli olarak tanımladım oyunculuk
anlamında yetenekliydi mama çalışmam
gerekiyordu ses anlamında öyle bir 4
oktav çoktan kocaman bir Sesim yok benim
çok çalıştım yetenekle çalışmak bir
arada olduğu zaman güzel köpürüyor
çalışmazsanız yeteneğiniz hiçbir işe
yaramıyor eleştirileri o sert
eleştirileri sizi aşağıya çekmek isteyen
eleştirileri dikkate alırsanız onlardan
başka yapacak hiçbir şey yok Peki
eleştiri nedir eleştiri içinde bir çözüm
bir öneri bir fikir Taşıyan şeyin ismi
eleştirilir yerleştiriyor eleştiriyi
yapan insanın Şahsi husumetleri Ne kendi
yapamadıklarını ve hayatta olan
intikamını içeriyorsa eğer dedi demedi
dedikodu bunda nelere gitmiyor kapayın
kulaklarınızı Bence ben kapıyorum
Bu ürünü ve duymuyorum Hayır eğer sosyal
medyada Benimle ilgili yazılan
çizilenleri ciddiye alsaydık Eğer ben
beni öldürdüler gönüllüler kırgın çıktı
ruhuma El Fatiha öldüm ben Yok öyle bir
şey çıktı Sokağı yedin Anadolu'ya her
yerini karış karış dolaşın böyle bir
gerçek Yok böyle bir zorbalık da yok
canımızı okuyorlar hiçbir zaman şiddeti
iletişim dili olarak kullanmadım
seçmedim seçme yiyeceğim de o yüzden
dedim kin tutmuyorum Avukat tutuyorum
diye bazen bazı insan çok komik
savundular yapabiliyor Gerçekten böyle
Avukat tutuldu Hangisine cevap veriyor
15 kişi konuşurken Hepsi Bir yandan
konuşurken nasıl savunabilirim ki ben
kendimi Ayrıca ben neden savunuyorum
kendimi
Sen kime hesap veriyorum ben niye hesap
veriyorum ben yıllar önce kızgın yine
böyle bir öbür taş verirken demişim ki
kafamda böyle iki tane kukulata
Unutmayın ki bana bir şey olmaz
Ya sen kimsin sadece bir şey olmaz
kestiler tanıma köyceğiz'in canım acıyor
işte de bence Unutmayalım ki çalışana ve
üreterek hiçbir şey olmaz bana olabilir
bir çalışan reten bir kadınım
ayaklarının üzerinde duran bir kadının
Arzu ettiğim hayatı yaşıyorum çok mutlu
bir evlilik yaptım Çok da mutlu bir
şekilde boşandım karar verdim ona ben
karar verdim Annem karar verememişti
Annem çalışmıyordu ve başarılı değildi
ve gidecek yeri yoktu benim vardı can
havliyle verdiğim kararlardan birisi de
İkizlerim çok erken doğdular 7 aylık
doğdular iki buçuk ay yoğun bakımda
kaldık
bu ölümle yaşamın bu kadar yakın
olduğunu entübeden en kelimenin ne
anlama geldiğini yoğun bakımda yaşadım
kalbi durmak
Ben de tekrar kalbinin çalışması da uzak
Kısa bir süre ki o ben hastanede iki
buçuk ay boyunca bunları yaşarken Bilge
köyünde Mardin'de bildiği köyünde
katliam oldu var mı hatırlayanınız çok
çok çok acı bir cinayette namussuzun
teki namus cinayeti işlemiş tip attım
Bilge köyüne gittim Mardin'de Bilge
köyünü ziyaret ettim Sabah gittim Akşam
döndüm
bu döndüğümde
ve o kadar bir şey yapmam gerektiğini
hissediyorum ki Ne yapmam gerekiyor
çikolata götürmek değil monte almak
değil ayakkabı almak değil kaldı ki
bunlar da çok önemli Bunlar da yapılmalı
ama bir kök salmak istedim toprağa bir
kök salmak istedim kalıcı bir iyilik
yapmak istedim Bir seneye yakın düşündüm
araştırdım ne yapabilirim ne yapabilirim
selülitleri var bunalıma girdi Selin
ipleriyle yakaladık
bu sebeplerim var Kama bunalıma girmedim
Gülben Ergen ip bittiği an
bir bitmedim çalışıyorum ve üretiyorum
çünkü ama sen Ümitlerim lebide başka bir
konuya O kadar büyük yer alamadığı 40
tane Anaokulu açtık Pardon 39 tane açtık
40000 Çiğdem nisan ayında açacağız
anaokulları ve çocuklar gülsün diye
Derneği ni kurmam
ben yoluma Conan taşları size burada 18
dakikaya sığdırıp anlatmam mümkün değil
Reklamını yapıyor Nehir reklamını
yapacağım benim menajerim bana da güzel
bu da çok anaokul açıyorsun çocuklarla
fotoğraf koyuyorsunuz Vallahi işlerimiz
azaldı hiç kimse anaokulu öğretmeni gibi
bir kadını sahneye çıkartmak istemiyor
Doğrudur ben katkıda bulunma Saydım
arkasından itekleme sevdim bütün
gittiğim televizyon programlarında Bir
tane de SMS Siz atar mısınız çocuklar
gülsün diye Derneği küpten iznimiz var
ot yazı geçirir misiniz oraya gittik
buraya gidiyoruz Trabzon'da gitmemiz
lazım Van'a gitmemiz lazım Adana'ya
gitmemiz lazım Giresun'a gitmemiz lazım
bugün mücadele Bu ülkenin Kadim
değerlerinden birisidir paylaşmak
bu paylaşmayı seviyorum ve insanlar
ikiye ayırıyorum iyi insanlar kötü
insanlar başka hiçbir insan ayrım yok
çocuklar için yaratılan fırsat
eşitsizliği beni çok rahatsız ediyor
derde ediyorum Bunu kendime
Ben kendimi seviyorum kendimi sayıyorum
Bu size kendinizi sevin sayın önünüze
çıkan engellerin hiçbirini ki hiçbirini
dikkate almayın yoksa başarılı
olamazsınız var saydınız var olur Yok
saydınız yok olur yetenekli yeseniz bile
çalışmazsanız olmaz Ben çalışmayı ve iyi
bir insan olmayı seçiyorum bu
yargılamamak bu hesap sormak ülkemizin
toplumun iliklerine işlemiş durumda bu
çözüm değil ben hiç sorunu
odaklanamıyorum çözüme odaklanmayı
seçiyorum sizde çözüm yoluna gidin
teşekkür ederim beni dinlediğiniz için